stellen sie sich einmal vor sie bauen
ein unternehmen mit auf das dann
millionenschwer ist so geschehen bei
lawrence leuschner der jetzt aber alle
seine anteile an der firma tier die
grün-weißen elektro-roller kennen sie
bestimmt alle verschenken möchte und
warum man das macht das kann man
natürlich nur ihn selber fragen deswegen
mir jetzt live zugeschaltet lawrence
leuschner ihre anteile 15 prozent an dem
unternehmen sind natürlich millionenwert
warum haben sich jetzt dafür entschieden
diese zu verschenken
ja also für mich war wie jetzt der
zeitpunkt gekommen dass ich sage ich
will etwas zurückgeben ich glaube dass
es viel wichtiger ist in die zukunft des
planeten zu investieren als mehr
monetären wohlstand zu erreichen und da
ich alles hat was ich brauche eine gute
beziehung einen gesunden körper habe ich
gesagt okay jetzt lass uns doch mal
schauen wie können wir das nutzen und in
die zukunft des planeten investieren
indem man unternehmern unternehmerinnen
unterstützt
auch impact bis es zu bauen und was
genau soll jetzt mit diesem geld
passieren wenn genau wollen sie damit
unterstützen
ich glaube ich habe eine vereinbarung
getroffen mit von splash dass eine
stiftung und wir haben entschieden dass
das geld in ein impact vorgeht der nennt
sich bei impact den habe ich ins leben
gerufen und mit diesem fonds werden
unternehmen unternehmerin unterstützt
ihre visionen von einer nachhaltigen
zukunft zu bauen und zu verwirklichen
und das sonne daran ist dass selbst mit
diesen unternehmen irgendwann der gewinn
abwerfen oder verkauft werden dann kann
der von mir nichts zurück auszahlen das
heißt ich habe davon keinen persönlichen
benefit außer dass ich viel mehr und
viel besser sehen kann dass wir die
bendandi die welt ein bisschen besser
machen können